Today we'll be speaking with doctor Gerald core on emotion and cognition.
Dr Core is a Commonwealth professor of psychology at the University of Virginia
and formerly an alumni distinguished professor at the University of Illinois.
His research focuses on emotion and it's cognitive consequences.
He's coauthored the cognitive structure of emotions,
a general theory of how psychological situations elicit emotions and make them
intense.
It's chief application is in computer science as the emotion engine of
intelligent agents and robots,
computer games and interactive training modules.
His research has been funded by both the NIH and NSF and concerns.
The effect is information hypothesis,
which clarifies how emotional information about value and urgency help to shape
or regulate cognition,
motivation,
and even memory.
Dr Clore has served as an associate editor of cognition and emotion as faculty
in the Nih consortium on emotion and as a visiting professor at Harvard
University.
He's also been a visiting scholar at Harvard,
Oxford in New York University and a fellow of the Centers for advanced study,
Illinois,
Stanford and the Rockefeller Center in Italy.
In 2010 he was elected to the American Academy of Arts and Sciences.
And in 2013 he received the William James Award for scientific achievement from
the association for Psychological Science.
Today,
I'm very delighted to have Dr Gerald core from the University of Virginia
speaking with us today on emotion and cognition.
So welcome,
Jerry.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thank you.
So I wanted to start out,
Jerry,
by asking you a bit about what first got you interested in emotion?
Well,
I was a graduate student at the University of Texas and we were working on
interpersonal attraction,
uh,
and at the time the theories of why you like April emphasized people's beliefs
about other people you like,
people that you know,
positive things about.
Uh,
but it seemed to me that surely liking was more a matter of feeling than
believing.
Uh,
so,
but the trouble is beliefs and feelings are hard to separate in the lab.
And actually a roommate of mine who was in graduate school at the time solve
this problem by simply showing happy or sad films to people and having them make
judgements about,
uh,
individuals that they had information about.
And what he found was that regardless of your beliefs about the other person,
if you felt better,
you like them better.
And that made a lot of sense to me.
Uh,
as a matter of fact,
uh,
Charlie's,
my,
my friend,
Charlie's method that he made up has now become a kind of standard social
psychological thing to do to induce irrelevant FX check to see how it works in
judgements and decision making and so forth.
Another kind of influenced,
I came soon that when I had become a professor at Illinois,
I did a study of conversations and we were trying to see what people said in
conversations that made other people like them.
But it turned out that much more important than what they sin.
It was what the razors got to say about themselves in the conversations.
So people when they felt rewarded and got to talk about themselves,
like the other person,
um,
uh,
which in the in a way is no surprise what we thought it was very important to
start with,
look at people's own responses as a determine of their view of the world.
And I guess the other main part of this is a colleague of mine at the University
of Illinois,
Andrew or Tony.
Uh,
and I started thinking about emotion and eventually wrote a book about an
emotion.
Um,
and the idea was to really make computers more emotionally intelligent.
Now the idea wasn't to make them feel anything,
but to give them a kind of emotion knowledge so that they could interact with
people and understand their emotions.
Um,
so we wrote this book and it covers a,
it has a theory that covers 22 emotions and what makes them occur and what makes
them intense or mile.
And it turned out to be the biggest hit in computer science.
So today if you look online under,
oh,
Si,
si or Tony Clore and Collins,
which is the authorship,
uh,
and anything else,
you can find lots of applications in computer science to games and tutors and
therapy and all kinds of stuff.
So
I guess that's that.
Excellent.
So I mean,
it's really interesting to hear about where your path and emotion first started.
And I mean,
since then you've been one of the most pioneering figures and thinking about
emotion generally and how it relates the way we think about the world.
And so what I wanted to ask you a bit about,
you know,
is your groundbreaking research that's really pioneered the way that we
understand this,
you know,
intricate,
um,
an important link between an affect and cognitive processes in terms of
specifically such as how effect influences things like judgment and your affect
is information theory.
So I wonder if you could say a bit about what are some of the fundamental
principles that are outlined in this approach of yours?
Well,
um,
I guess the key discovery that we made is that the impact of one's ethic really
depends on what its object is and the kind of classic them duration of that it
was.
And the experiments that Norbert Schwarz,
who was a postdoc at the time,
uh,
and I did in the early eighties,
and we called people on the phone on sunny or rainy spring day is in the Midwest
at the University of Illinois.
Uh,
and people were a little happier on sunny days and not so happy on cold and
rainy days.
And we've been asked them,
we gave them a little too item life satisfaction interview.
Uh,
and we discovered that on when people were happy,
they thought life in in general was pretty good.
And when they were less happy,
they thought life in general was not saying it well.
There's lots of ways to explain that of course.
But what we,
an additional group was refers to ask some of them about the weather,
uh,
making salient this real cause of how they felt.
And for those people there was no relationship between their mood and,
uh,
the life satisfaction.
Because all the feelings were about something else.
So it really taught us this lesson about the impact of ethic being,
depending on what it seems to be about and shows that rather than being a
thoroughly automatic process.
It depends on how you parse your own experience.
Um,
of course,
uh,
in our experiments we often get people to misattribute their feelings.
So we show them a movie that you're relevant and then ask them the judgments
about their life.
And you might think,
well,
what a silly way to design a person,
uh,
in the real world.
I think people's feelings by and large are right on target.
People know,
well,
we think of it as information and people find it to be accurate information on
the whole.
So the experiments are not a good model in that sense for the way it isn't the
real world,
but they allow us to look inside and a way.
So in some ways,
I mean,
what do you,
what do you see as the most important and central discoveries?
I mean,
you've talked about some already.
Um,
you know,
outlined in this aspect is as information theory.
Well,
uh,
some years ago we actually laid out a series of principles that we thought some
of these experiments illustrated.
And,
uh,
and I again,
I think the overarching one is this idea that it all depends on once the object
is and a lot of emotion and ethic research is all focused on the ethic and
emotion itself.
But again,
it's what it's about.
Emotions we think are more situated and then people realize,
so they're really more about that current situation.
Um,
and of course the emotion places,
constraints on how people think and so forth.
Uh,
but again,
a lot of the power lies in the object.
And the reason these experiments can work.
Yes.
Because is always about what is currently in mind.
It's always about the moment.
And so if you ask somebody about their life satisfaction while you've made them
feel good,
they're suddenly attend how they feel and it's,
it appears to be about life satisfaction.
Uh,
so in that sense,
moods and depression and affective of states that lasts through time can be a
problem.
Um,
well there are a number of,
there's about a dozen principals,
but I won't go through them here.
Well,
one question I have for you is to what extent do you think this theory applies
equivalently across,
you know,
positive valence states on the one hand and negatively balanced states on the
other?
Well,
um,
it certainly does.
That is the bows are informed and uh,
uh,
positive ethics says that something is good and negative effect says that
something is bad.
Uh,
and one of the discoveries is that an important object is one's own thoughts,
uh,
which we'll talk about in a minute I think.
But yes,
negative aspect is as important as positive aspect,
uh,
because negative effect essentially says,
are you sure you want to do that?
Uh,
and often that's important.
So you mentioned we're going to talk about something in a second and well,
a second has passed.
So the question I have then is just,
I mean,
it's about the work you've done where you've really provided these novel
insights into the role of emotion in,
you know,
cognitive processing thinking and also problem solving.
And I wondered if you could tell us a bit more about some of the discoveries
that you found here that you think are especially important to know?
Well,
yes.
Um,
people,
it turns out,
do you think differently in different states?
We've looked primarily just at happy and sad states,
uh,
positive and negative feelings.
Uh,
so for example,
um,
we've gone through sort of the cognitive tech Expo
and looked at a Verot eddy of street cognitive phenomena and said,
what happens if you try a false memory experiment?
For example,
when people are happy,
when they're sad,
it turns out for a whole list of standard phenomena.
People only do the when they're happy.
As you go through the standard cognitive textbooks,
a lot of the standard phenomenon like semantic priming,
which is a very common,
easily produced phenomenon.
People feel even a little sad.
They don't show it.
People use stereotypes when they're happy.
People look at the big picture when they're happy.
There are a number of kinds of distinctive cognitive,
uh,
characteristics that seem to be tied to the positive and negative habit.
Well,
you can imagine a of theories grew up to explain this.
It was about a dozen current theories,
but recently we realized that all of them make one assumption that might be
wrong,
including the explanations that we've offered.
Um,
they all assume that these specific effective states really are dedicated to a
particular kind of thinking.
And it finally occurred to us that that may not be true.
So,
uh,
and,
and the bottom line here is going to be that rather than a happy mood making you
look at the big picture,
for example,
it makes you do whatever you're ready to do.
So we,
uh,
did a series of experiments in which we,
changed what people were prepared to do.
So for example,
most of us,
most of the time look at a somewhat expanded view of things.
That's just the default.
So in an experiment,
we made the default the opposite to look at details,
to be very local in focus.
And then we,
again,
an induced to happy and sad mood.
And the question was,
so we'll happy mood make you global or local.
What we found was that happy mood made you do whatever you were ready to do.
So in these cases,
people were ready to look at the details and the happy people started looking at
the details and the sad people looked at the big picture because the sad mood
said,
don't do that.
You are about to do.
Don't do that.
Uh,
well,
we've now done lots of experiments and just about any mood related phenomena,
it can be turned on its head,
uh,
by changing what the default is by what people are,
what's accessible.
Uh,
and so it's sort of fun to,
to overturn partly our own work as well as her friends and work and see it's a
little bit simpler.
So positive effect in thinking is a little like reward.
It's not dedicated to anything in particular.
Perhaps it just says yes,
uh,
to whatever's online or no.
In the case of negative ethic,
now
we automatically evaluate everything.
Uh,
and positive effect is good in the sense that it says,
yes,
do what you're good at,
what you're ready to do.
But of course,
sometimes you don't want to do that.
And negative ethic is important because it says,
no,
not here,
not now.
Um,
I sometimes mentioned that,
uh,
John Dewey and his theory of education,
I kind of a father of American education theory had a kind of the same idea.
He said,
you don't really learn anything unless you reach a problem until your negative
FX is no do something new,
don't the same old thing.
So do you think that there are certain kinds of cognitive processes that may be
most intimately related to effect some more than others?
Okay.
Well that's an interesting question.
Um,
it looks to me like just about anything,
that that ethic is much more central than I think we've ever thought.
So it governs how we act,
how we perceive,
uh,
and what we remember.
We remember things that are emotionally arousing,
uh,
Eh,
eh,
are a couple of days after emotional arousal.
Even if the arousal occurs after what you learn,
you remember it really well,
which is of course sadly what happens in something like PTSD or other trauma
related problems.
So if guns,
his memory and influences judgment,
it influences decision making.
I'm attracted to the idea proposed by a Roy Baumeister that,
uh,
mm,
the,
the bottom line and decision making really is anticipated ethic.
We do metal simulations and make a decision if we,
if we anticipate,
oh,
that's going to work out well of course.
Uh,
but in some sense there's a lot of work on emotion and decision making.
Not all of it wonderful.
Uh,
but it seems to me that's sort of the overall truth.
Mm hmm.
So I'm not sure I can find any cognitive process to that,
that it doesn't implies
hm.
Like you're saying,
it just permeates all of our sort of thinking life,
you know,
so to speak.
Well,
we evaluate things and evaluations are crucial to actions.
Right.
So thinking about,
you know,
some of the other work that you've been doing,
um,
I mean,
you've also conducted this really fascinating work looking at the role of an
effect in what some people think of as more cognitively complex processes such
as moral judgments.
And I wonder if you could say a little bit about your work here,
where you've looked at the role of a particular kind of emotion,
disgust,
you know,
and how that might actually influence the kinds of moral judgments we make about
what's good and what's bad.
Yes.
We,
uh,
a former postdocs and Otis Chenault,
and I decided to see if discuss a specific emotion would inform decisions and
judgments just like happy and sad mood does.
Uh,
so we did a variety of experiments in which we made people disgusting man in
various ways.
One of them was to have people sit at a,
in a very messy room,
uh,
and a desk with dirty,
clean axes.
And we gave them a chewed up pencils to work with and it was thoroughly
disgusting.
Uh,
or in one case we used a commercially available fart spray to discuss them.
Or we simply had the,
asked them to think about lots of disgusting thing,
which is pretty effective.
And then we gave them,
well,
we did one of these things at a time and then gave them moral standard moral
judgments scenarios to ask them.
So is this behavior Mrl or is this okay?
Uh,
things like the trolley problem,
some people may have heard them.
And what we found is that when people felt disgusted,
they tended to see morally ambiguous things as immoral.
Uh,
it moved their set point about what was immoral,
especially for people who said they paid attention to their own bodily
reactions.
Not so much for people who don't,
but that sort of fit into the larger story that we use our own affective
reactions as information.
And this then led to another,
a former student,
uh,
and I had to,
Gary Sherman to,
to do a series of studies.
We've been working on color perception of black and white.
Uh,
and it occurred and we were looking at that and evaluation.
And it occurred to Gary that,
um,
you may not be about good and bad generally,
but about morality.
So we developed something called moral stroop test in which we simply ask people
to name the color of the font black or white against a gray background,
uh,
when the words were either moral or immoral in meaning angel,
devil,
Sin a charity.
And so forth.
And we found that for people who were disgusted,
it was,
they were slow in saying white when the word was devil or black when the word
was charity or something.
So a real stroop effect.
But it was heightened by disgust and a general tendency to be discussed,
sensitive as well.
Actually the most recent one that just came out and psych science recently,
um,
we,
well we looked,
we had people see if they could see numbers,
uh,
printed against a background,
the same colors that we might have a quite number two against a white background
or every shade of gray and difference between the number and the background.
And we found this amazing thing,
which is that when people are quite disgusted,
these are people who were high and disgust sensitivity that we made disgust for
that group.
They were actually more perceptive.
They were more accurate in seeing what the rest of us couldn't see.
They could accurately seek,
read the number against the background that looked identical.
Uh,
and this was interestingly true only at the white end of the continuum at the
dark end,
no different.
So when disgusted,
well discussed,
then kind of not only makes us want to avoid impurities,
but it actually better able to detect them.
Yeah.
So you can sit down,
not inconsistent with other data about,
for example,
fear,
I mean enhancing visual acuity and other ways in which emotion seems to affect
perception as well as thought.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's just a really interesting,
this special role that disgusts,
seems to play in rural judgments from all the really interesting insights.
And you just talked about in your work,
it makes me wonder,
you know,
to what extent do we think about aspect more generally and influencing moral
judgments?
Can't,
can we think of it as a general sort of relationship or is it really specific to
things like discussed?
Well,
uh,
just about any evaluative judgment is going to involve ethic.
It seems to me,
uh,
and,
it's a good question because the research that Gary and I have done really makes
it look like disgust is specifically about the purity aspect of morality.
And according to my former colleague John Height,
there are about five different moral intuitions are which purity is only one.
Uh,
so it remains to be seen in a way.
Yeah.
So many things that are on the future horizon of emotion.
Um,
which makes me think about it a little bit.
from your perspective,
I mean,
where do you see the future of emotion research headed?
What,
what is the horizon out there?
Yeah,
well,
that's a good question.
Yeah.
Uh,
I recently wrote a chapter for a handbook,
a call,
five new ideas about emotion.
And there were five new ideas that appeared in the last five years.
There's a lot happening in the study of motion.
And then basic things like asking again,
well,
what is an emotion and how does it arise and what,
how does it influence cognition and perception and actions on it?
MMM.
And I think one of the more interesting developments is the idea that,
uh,
how to emotion,
well,
let me back up.
Let's think of a,
like a behavioral ecologist.
Humans like other animals as they're,
as they're,
as having their behavior guided by ultimate concerns,
like their resources.
And if you watch him a bird or an animal,
then this environment,
everything that it does is guided by the necessity to achieve certain resource
gains and defend itself and,
and have shelter and so forth.
And surely we're not that different.
So an interesting development is to look at at emotion as a signal about that
assists in resource management.
We did a couple of experiments with a colleague Denny profit,
uh,
in which we get made people sad and had had them judge the slant of the hill.
Something that profit does regularly.
There's judge slams.
They'll be found that when you're sad a hill look steeper and if you're on top
of a hill and you're frightened because you're standing on a skateboard,
it looks deeper.
And a variety of studies are now being done.
Looking at making it look like emotion,
um,
is concerned in part with resource management.
That is the general position of profit is that our perception is informed by how
tired we are or how much resources,
how many resources we got.
But,
uh,
my former postdoc,
Simona Chanel,
took this in an especially interesting direction saying,
well,
for humans,
social resources are remarkably important.
We are the ultra social species.
We're the only species perhaps that cooperate with non-kin,
please cooperate.
But they're all related,
uh,
within a high.
But we cooperate with strangers.
We will form teams and we'll even sacrifice for each other.
And so the question is,
how does that work?
How does all this hyper sociality keep us together?
Uh,
and I think the answer is the social emotions.
If you start listing emotions,
uh,
you'll discover that gene,
most of them are social,
emotional,
gratitude and love and jealousy and brief and on and on.
Right?
And so the idea,
perhaps it's interesting that these emotions are helping us,
well,
get an information about and motivate us to act in a way that maintains our
resources.
Uh,
that is,
we're all going to be in groups and work together.
We care a lot about whether other people who are trustworthy.
So a lot of what we do is to show other people,
I'm a good group member,
I'm trustworthy and loyal.
Uh,
and when we find somebody who isn't,
we all gossip about them and make sure everybody knows you don't trust that
person anyways.
So the ultimate resource for humans is perhaps needs social resources and an
awful lot of human emotion.
It's really about the management of those sources perhaps,
but not much has been done from that perspective.
And there's a whole lot of interesting questions for,
for new investigators to think about.
I think
I'm in,
so you're talking about new investigators and it makes me wonder,
when your investigators come to you,
um,
post docs,
graduate students,
undergraduates asking you for advice,
they're thinking about maybe embarking into this field of emotion,
um,
what kind of advice do you give them?
Okay,
well,
um,
okay.
One of the things that I say often to students is that I try to encourage them
not to be social psychologists or a cognitive psychologist or clinical
psychologist,
but psychologists to kind of take a broader view,
uh,
because again,
consistent with the idea about the resources,
I guess,
um,
emotions,
part of a much larger system and we're not really going to understand it just by
looking at,
at this emotion phenomenon and that emotion phenomenon without thinking also how
does it fit into some larger picture?
So emotion like a jigsaw puzzle pieces more interesting once you see it fitting
in
in the hole.
I just want to thank you again for joining us today.
It was great to hear your insights and hear a bit about your thoughts on
cognition and emotion,
Jerry,
so thank you.
Well,
thank you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Dr. Gerald Clarke from
the University of Virginia.